but coronavirus could soon arrive in the
valley with a Vengeance if our waste
water is any indication Christian
casares joining us now live in studio
with a closer look at this new
Wastewater data that's right Brian will
data from UNLV shows big spikes in
covid-19 DNA levels in the Wastewater in
both Las Vegas and in Henderson
Wastewater surveillance remains an
important component of understanding
what's happening with covid-19 according
to the Southern Nevada Water Authority
although the state is reporting a
decline in covid-19 cases over the past
week in Clark County data from UNLV
indicates otherwise an enormous spike in
levels of covid-19 material detected in
the Wastewater in Las Vegas and a bigger
spike in Henderson Wastewater monitoring
can provide early awareness of potential
outbreaks because people who have been
infected can take several days before
showing symptoms according to UNLV as a
result the information can help direct
testing and resources during a surge
surgeon Wastewater levels could
foreshadow an increase in cases but
there's no guarantee that will happen
water officials saying the drinking
water is treated to remove pathogens
including the virus that causes covid-19
and there is no evidence that the virus
is viable as it travels through sewage
systems
well as nevadans continue to gather for
the holidays the Biden Administration is
doing a fourth round of free covet test
kits in hopes to prevent the spread you
can check out 8newsnow.com for a link to
place your order shipping begins
December 19th